Harold Reynolds is in the batter's box
here three gold gloves
he actually loaned us one for a little
while and then took it back two-time
all-star Major League Baseball Network
analyst MLB Network is live coverage
before and after every League
Championship Series and World Series
game you can watch HR on MLB tonight
from Yankee Stadium tonight that'll be
it to 6:00 p.m.
and Al Leiter a boy will be there though
with you doing a little pregame with Al
it'll be awesome a favorite baseball
movie of all time
that you said all right I can buy into
that I mean Phil the dreams is awesome
okay okay you know but did you look at
Boulder is Bull Durham accurate there's
a lot of yeah there's a lot of things
there these I saw in the minor leagues
no doubt but you didn't see Susan
Sarandon and no but I think you had that
type of a character in a lot of cities
no you did yeah well you know the guy
was in love with this older woman who
was trying to get out of town and you
know what's the strangest thing you saw
in the minor leagues out of a strange
but one of my my favorite stories is we
were on a bus ride about 14 hours all
right
and Rick Adair who went on to be a
pitching coach to the Indians and all
that he's one of my my dear friends he's
like supposed to pitch the day game the
next day and he's like we won't be
playing boys and he watered the field
down he set the hose down on the field
water to death for like four hours we
got into three or four in the morning he
watered the field down they canceled the
game wait so Crash Davis does it in the
movie Bull Durham he had it before Crash
Davis
that was probably 1980 so I don't know
what time crash didn't I think that's a
but that was legendary guys used to do
stuff like that now I did have a owner
in double-a ball and Lynn Mass in 1982
who every time we broke a bat we had to
bring it back to him to get a new one
so we basically only had two or three
bats in your bat rack you broke one you
had to take it to him and you had to
plead with him you go it's cracked right
here Eddy Lite tape it up it's okay and
like this you can't tape it tape it up
put a couple tacks in
you'll be good and we would play with
attacked up taped up bat for another
three or four games is that legal
no it's not I'm going to guess it if
that had shattered you had like nails
flying towards the pictures it was all
over the place cutting your hands yeah
yes how long were you in the minors I
spent three about three and a half
seasons and then when you got called up
I got called up in September
what was that call like it was awesome
but we we had like six guys get called
up so it was almost like we're on the
road in the hotel and you can hear
somebody yelling in my room alright so
yeah we got we got called up me and Dave
Ali that we're rooming together we got
called at the same time that's September
Seattle is the only franchise yet to
make it to a World Series it's tough to
tell it's not your fault no well I mean
I had ten years of it being my father I
guess we could have got there back in
you guys had Seattle's had as much
talent as anybody has has anybody mean
you have jr. and a rod we had a team
when you're doing your a rod Randy
Johnson Edgar on the same club with Jay
Buhner
so you have four Hall of Famers on there
yes and you don't make the World Series
no and that's hard to look back at man
yeah but I don't know where they're at
right now I mean they're there present
day there are long ways away
you know the whole yeah they're still
reimagining the roster or whatever
they're saying now but it's gonna be
tough for the Mariners for a few more
years to get back all right I'm glad you
stopped by I know you're going to Yankee
Stadium and who does the rainout help
most all the Astros you know just
because it started pitching you watched
Game one the Yankees went to the bullpen
early PacSun then went they're gonna go
again with Tanaka and they're gonna you
know their bullpen their whole thing is
set on the strength of that pin so the
more you see the pin the advantage goes
to Houston but also they wear down so I
think the Astros get a huge advantage
you think the Astros are the better team
I thought they were the best team in
baseball yeah
these are better than I thought they
were though watching them in September
it looked like they went to another
level glamour tours stud 22 years old
second baseman I think he's like Robbie
Alomar type no Aaron judge he continues
to just show up and do his thing there's
Jim Carlos Stanton want to play baseball
yeah he wants to play I know Reggie was
all over him the other day it's been a
tough run for him you gotta play through
some of this play it's the playoffs
of course and I got to think he wants to
get out there I don't know what happens
but a lot of times in today's game I
mean guys get hurt they take you out
instantly you know I wouldn't think that
would be the mindset of the postseason
this is more on him probably do you see
lows management coming into baseball
like it has the NBA give me that load
management you know like Kawhi Leonard
yeah play 60 games
oh that's happening already you know
you're the Angels do you do that with
Mike Trout I know we're doing it with
natures but everything is geared towards
the postseason so do I want to have Mike
Trout playing in 162 games well it's
tough because he's selling tickets I
want to see my child play not that the
NBA doesn't have that as well but I
think you can back Mike Trout off you
they will no doubt about it we're seeing
guys now where if a guy catches a
hundred games that's considered a big
year where hundred games you know so
that was that's that's where we're at
now guys for 130 games and that's why
Yadier Molina is gonna go to the Hall of
Fame I mean he then uses everything yes
you say he's good at catchers we've
probably ever had call with all the
analytics all the numbers and that's
where we're at
everybody's figuring out things
statistically what are gonna get the
best product on the field and whether
you like it or not that's where the
games at so yeah they'll be back in guys
off if you're Joe Maddon would you
consider trading Mike Trump if I'm Joe
Maddon no I want Mike Trout but if I was
the Angels I said this two years ago
that they should have traded my trout I
think you would have got a Herschel
Walker type of deal back and
those are the younger crowd they got
googly Google Play errs and change the
whole organization I've thought that but
now it's a 500 million dollar contract
so it's a little bit different than when
it was a hundred and forty million so I
don't know because we can take a great
player doesn't give you a great regular
everyday player doesn't insure you
anything you got a pitch I gotta have
two great pitchers you got a pitch and
that's that's really if you said and you
guys know this with Seattle was built
for the regular season when Seattle won
116 games yeah not built for the
postseason because you didn't have
hammers out there if I bring in
Schilling and Pedro Schilling in unit I
got Gerrit Cole and I got Verlander man
that is such a luxury in a seven-game
series you got to face those guys four
out of seven games I like my chances no
no well I look at the Washington
Nationals yes everybody's like why are
the Nationals in I felt like when you
have Scherzer and you have Strasburg and
you have Patrick Corbin you can beat the
Dodgers and next thing you know you beat
the Cardinals and you got a chance to
win a World Series even against the
Yankees or the Astros who probably are
the gonna be the favored team but you
get those three starters you got shot do
you think Bryce Harper's rooting for the
Nationals yeah yes those are guys they
grew up with I may not be if I know they
don't know but he grew up with those
guys a matter of fact I talked to his
dad the other day you know they were
pulling for the Nationals I know Bryce
I'm known in a long time and he's doing
ok in Philly I think he believes he'll
win and I think he still thinks he made
the right decision but I still I know
that he Y is the right decision as
you've always about the most money well
I you know I shot I went to San Diego
and nobody cares yeah I think different
than Harvard I think Harper truly needed
a change of scenery I just think he was
that the only place he could go well I
came down to what what we've heard maybe
San Francisco Philly who else was in at
300 million with the Dodgers in this at
all I don't think they really got that
far of a concussion
talked about there was Cubs rumored but
I don't know who actually sat there and
said here's a deal do you want to come
here I noticed that the home runs are
down in the postseason
mm-hmm is there a reason pitching in a
couple balls that have been hit that you
go oh that was a home run in the summer
I can see people saying that but I can't
trust Major League Baseball because I
know I can't believe them if they say no
no we're not doing anything to the
baseball HR come on 6,000 home runs well
and then now it's flying that can't deny
that but I can say this in the
postseason every year it doesn't matter
if it was back in the 80s or now yeah
there's not many home runs and
postseason pitching dominates and it's
more focused it's not 162 games they're
more isolated we're seeing more pitchers
that's why there's so much bull penning
and strategic moves you don't see that
during the season it's too much did they
just make the baseball better like they
did they I don't know Dan if it's not
it's a I think it's a combination of
things
there's the balls jumping no doubt about
it but the bats are better the players
are stronger equipment they're more
efficient with their swings they're
trying to hit homeruns it's like for
example you grew up and you were gonna
dribble pass people and dish a ball now
that shoot threes they perfected the
three-pointer
these guys have perfected the long ball
swing well that wasn't the generation I
grew up with you know we were gonna bunt
we're gonna hit and run ball away I
could hit it the opposite field
I hardly ever see that now what would
you do if you're the Commissioner to get
to make baseball more interesting well
to me I still think it's interesting for
me I like I think there's some great
young talent but one thing I would do is
I would ban the shift I thought I would
never say that
because it's to me as a player who
played in the eighties and nineties it
was the onus is on you to beat the
defense they've been there forever right
well clearly this is not happening will
explain what what you're talking about
this well what you would ban with the
shift well I would I would put two
defenders on each side and I just like
in basketball you have man-to-man
defense or you have
zones you change it with the generations
and I think with baseball
we've lost the athleticism in the
infield we're not seeing that great play
up the middle and the throw back to
first base and guys moving why because
of standing right field and it's weird
to go to a game and see eight guys stand
on one side of the field so I'm forcing
the defenses to have to play normal and
I think it would change how the game is
played and perceived why don't I force
the hitter to hit it the other way
Harold they're not getting paid to do it
you know if that's just not you're not
you're getting paid for homeruns long
ball on-base percentage that's that's
where that's where the games at but
nobody had that incredible year so the
balls lively everybody's hitting home
runs but how how do you explain that
nobody had that you know 60 home runs
season maybe it's not the ball no I
don't know I think a lot of guys yeah
nobody had that big 60 and maybe
steroids are out of the game
well steroids the drug test is truly the
best we're seeing that clearly I think
this is just a product of guys being
able to be proficient they work their
tails off
it's bigger stronger every sport that's
just the way it is wasn't Junior ken
griffey jr. didn't he have a launch
angle before we knew what a launch angle
was well yeah I think what what the
difference is in my mind how I look at
it we should be calling it launch counts
you know there when it was two and O
three and one what are you trying to do
it try to the ball the ballpark I don't
care if it's wiffle ball in the backyard
or whatever it might be and so I think
what these guys are doing
everything's three in one they're taking
what they calls their a swing so they're
trying to hit a home run with every
swing so yes you're gonna change a
little bit of your arc and yeah Griffey
had that I'm a change of natural arc
but most left-handers do but he didn't
try to hit a homerun on every three
pitches he saw but if he played now he'd
be doing that he'd probably hit 70 home
runs
what would Bonds do no telling I still
wonder if you pitch to bonds when he
when he got walk about 200 times one
season like if you 230 times he got
walked yeah let's say you pitch to him
half of those
he's hitting 90 homeruns he might be it
would probably be like the great Rickey
Henderson told me when I want a stolen
base title he called me up he says 60
stolen bases you ought to be ashamed
[Laughter]
Ricky called you up to make fun of you
oh yeah no yes I win the stolen base
title and Ricky got hurt that year he
had like 30 it's the only time in the
eighties you can google it all right I
get home season ends phone rings
Henderson here is the ice Austin third
problem yeah so what's up Rick he goes
man ought to be ashamed I go what I said
60 stolen bases shame I always think of
Rickey Henderson I think of James Brown
the Entertainer
I just I just do for some reason I love
Ricky man he is something else
Ricky B Ricky Harold B Harold MLB
Network live coverage before and after
every LCS in World Series game who knows
they'll probably win another Sports Emmy
and steal it from us MLB tonight Yankee
Stadium tonight at 6:00 p.m.
tune in and check out HR no good buddy
Al Leiter thank you guys stopping by but
appreciate for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]